commute to this video playing there's
mustard or odd and going to see what he
does against my exchange anyplace you
place this him okay so I'm testing the
Bishop b5 line from the XL Smith
repertoire oh my god
is it c4 immediately or after castles
hmm
c4 things before I think it's it's this
immediately okay you can do that
interesting
I mean it looks like I'm keeping the
pawn here ah okay
that's interesting so if I take here
it's going to take on f3 probably hmm
and then some night is six stuff
yeah it's hard to play anything else
mm-hmm yeah but this this should be okay
right check and take care black wind
reform this must be okay I mean okay in
the sense that white is slightly better
be sure before coming I was worried
about Bishop takes a dream
Jim hmm ticking ticking is the blame but
it's also tough to do anything else
really but okay it's it's it's still not
super easy for from black liking a
rookie one and he doesn't have a super
comfortable way of playing without
canceling my kinga seven or so it
doesn't work f6 but then you know the 94
496 this is this is not not all that
comfortable BPM cannot move the C pawn
rook c8 I call 96 maybe not totally sure
if this is good if he takes it it is
good fit and that is probably not such a
bad decision I simply simply giving this
up I have to take it down I mean
otherwise I think the whole thing didn't
make much sense I don't take it yeah
here I will get to e7 which is probably
not it's probably not super pro he
allows me to do this that's surprising
okay and you know it looks a bit sick to
do this trade but it has one advantage
I'm getting rid of the opposite colored
bishops
so look c4 is the thing
[Music]
maybe I have to regroup this 2c3
rook c2fo is winning so he cannot go
Roxy to check this was running into
running into some fog King e4 Knight c3
King at 594 and so on
clingy 693 yeah which it - I still have
two winner Jim is there anything is
there a better move no probably not iam
check still have two winner Jim look
aged to 55 King c6 if he gets be true
this is not not super easy to win
okay let's say Knight takes one takes B
- I'm not totally sure what the cleanest
way of winning is I only have two pawns
at the end
this always makes it a little bit
difficult check oh I was thinking he
would go to the other side there's now a
six is dropping but yeah he gets to f5
of course that'sthat's true
[Music]
check right only to isn't the most
active piece album
yeah it should be sufficient to win okay
if I check first
I think I'm avoiding check the doubling
of the points time morning King f3 I can
flick rook air-five that isn't a problem
this one okay f1 f1
and they have route a7 as well f forces
again it's not possible I may be king g5
now but I have rugae six
I think I'm slowly getting them
kingi for k7 I also have to get porn so
I can use this once in a while
okay maybe use the night
check check check check
five I don't know
that wasn't the last four fits on time
if Nikhil play ever maybe yeah okay it
helped a little bit that I was up one
time it was interesting in the opening
yeah I don't I don't really don't really
know if he should have taken on f3 right
like he should be 6th and that's very
interesting with Bishop d5 and it seems
that he knew the whole thing yeah yeah
that was I was thinking at this this
should be a particularly of 3 should be
critical maybe I'm I'm wrong but I felt
this may be to try to use my king and
the engine just doesn't agree at all
yeah maybe it is just not not all that
much I mean I'm not claiming that that
was terrible for black I just during the
game I was check more worried about the
other thing when he I was thinking if
anything
slightly better with the partner with
the pawn weaknesses that black hairs but
he's decently developed yeah big sticks
rupee one and now the engine things
taking si 695 yes mmm that looks good
hmm so peeling probably 94 immediately
was bettin white should have a little
something here because of the pawn
structure of course the drawing margin
is very very wide and with the with the
opposite colored bishops but yeah and no
now it gets it gets annoying I think he
was correcting giving up the pawn
that was a good solution and here I was
this surprised me a lot I was thinking
he just goes here and the mania always
has King g6 that group e7 doesn't really
do all that much
I think the drawing chances here should
be very good and yeah I was very happy a
chicken that I could yeah that I was
getting rid of the the opposite colored
bishops this yeah 92 I think makes sense
and he fell right into that trap were
there for it mean it wasn't just a cheap
trap I wanted to get this here and then
look on d2 so that there the C file is
blocked and drug d2 covers the pawn and
then everything f2 and so on I think
that was a good technical move
well he's channeled into that after
which check I should win but Chad we
still have to do it I am before was
better I can just keep it yeah I was I
was a bit surprised that he was going to
his six in the first place check check I
mean this is also also winning but
I think near the end chat made a pretty
silly mistake check now in this year's
can take just six in area and then it's
a draw
[Music]
yeah I relaxed a little bit seeing that
I was winning on time we are here work
with you seven escutcheon that's that's
very that's very clear with the jeep on
promoting yeah interesting so he in the
opening he played it okay
but right afterward some they could have
avoided problems by being a bit more
precise okay guys thanks for watching
has forgotten switch on and then as I
said it wasn't anything that I didn't
didn't tell you thanks for watching